Film Courage: How many pilots
have you helped writer sell?
Speaker/Story/Career Consultant, Author
Jen Grisanti: Right now I am at 105. 106
in action and I also just heard about
another one that would make it 107.
Film Courage: Wow. These are TV pilots
that for streaming or also network?
Jen: Both.
Film Courage: Both. Okay, great.
Jen: Both and so writers are aware when you
sell a pilot it doesn't mean it goes to series,
it means you're selling a pilot. I've had
I think seven shows now go to series where
they get picked up and they're on the air.
That is a ratio that's very important for
writers to be aware of. You can sell a pilot
but so many pilots are bought per season and
the percentage that get to series (that get
picked up) is a much smaller number. When
I opened my business my whole focal point as
a consultant was the recognition that the TV
pilot is everything in taking a non-working
writer into being a working writer or an
unrepresented writer to a represented writer.
My whole focus when I started my business was
how do I demystify the pilot writing process
so writers know how to write a script that
will sell because having that recognition is
what will lead to an outcome because scripts
need to hit it out of the ballpark in order for
something to sell in order for a writer to staff.
Film Courage: What are a few things that
new writers get wrong about selling a pilot,
in addition to they'll be bought but not
necessarily be made, which is news to me.
Jen: I would say some of the things they do wrong
is the strategy of the season arc. The season arc
and the central conflict for the car in that they
are torn in two different directions is everything
to the longevity of the show and I think the
mistake that writers make is they're so focused
on the pilot episode without the recognition of
are they building a big enough well to where we
can see one season or several seasons of Story
coming from the concept so is it just that they
don't have room for dilemma or is it just too
small of an idea what would stop someone from
having something that had a big enough Arc I
think the well what stops someone from having
a big enough Arc has to do with also moving the
mindset of a feature writer beginning middle end
to a TV writer which is you are bookending your
pilot with with a strategy that is setting up
season one so you you have your series Arc that
is book ending and setting up season one then if
the strategy of the pilot Arc is done correctly
the pilot Arc is one step toward the season one
question so by the end of the pilot we should have
a very clear sense of what is the internal and the
external question that is driving season one and
that's how you build a a season arc for example an
old show that more people know I The Split that
I watched recently has probably one of the best
season art setups of any show I've seen because
it creates three seasons based on the setup of
the father who was gone for 30 years the eldest
daughter who has a secret that could cost her
her marriage and the well of story that's coming
from a family law practice that has to do with
with family law and domestic disruption so those
three components bring in the idea of story and
those three components built three seasons
of story and then a show like Homeland the
older show that I was mentioning you look at the
brilliance of the season one setup with the idea
of is Brody the prisoner of war the turn or isn't
he and every episode is yes no yes no toward the
season one question how does a writer get in the
room with the right people to pitch a television
show there lies the mystery of so much the writer
should first focus on the writing so many writers
will get focused on how do I get in a room and
the thing is if the writing is where it needs
to be and hits it out of the ballpark you will get
into the room and a way I've seen every writer has
a different journey for how that happens you can
have writers who enter all the competitions and
enter some of the more well-known competitions and
hit at the finalist or semifinalist or above and
you and they'll start to get recognition within
the community because of how they're performing
in competitions you I've seen writers I always
with my writers tell them if you hit semi finals
or above in a competition let me know and I will
give you a shout out on all of my social social
media because I have a lot of executives agents
managers on my social media so my feeling is if
I see someone who's getting great accomplishments
in the competition world it means that something
is working so that's one channel then you have
the channel of the writing programs that are at
the studio and networks that are these diversity
programs or just writing fellowships where the
intention of the program is to identify out
of sometimes two to 3,000 submissions what
are the top eight writers that are at a level
that they could be a working writer and then
to help facilitate that outcome then you also
have the channel of just the pure strength of
the writing that you do the work to get it in
the right hands and that could involve working
as a writer's assistant and absorbing and being a
sponge and utilizing your relationships when your
script is in a strong enough place to get you to
an outcome so it all comes down to the script it
all comes down to knowing that you don't want to
get into a room until your script is at a level
that could sell also knowing that whatever happens
in that room if you land in the room too early and
you're not ready there's something to learn from
that as well does that happen a lot oh yes oh yes
I mean you have development Executives that are
listening to so many pitches a day that you can
I always I writers have to recognize that you
can go into a room and feel like you don't have
an audience because you have a blank look on the
development executives face which happens a lot
purposely because they don't want to give you
a sense of what what's going on inside or you
can have someone who has a bazillion fires that
they're putting out that they're attention isn't
quite there and I always tell writers you have
the power to read a room and know when you need
to grab their attention and know when you are
losing their attention how to bring it back so
never feel like when you're losing the room that
there is no way to bring it back because you can
bring it back and always in your mind with your
pitch have an idea of all right a a common place
that you lose a room when you're pitching is in
the character description and if you don't give
the log line and you're giving this rambling view
of the characters and the the people hearing your
pitch are trying to think of the framework of
who is significant in what way and why you're
losing them so then you can help save yourself by
if you recognize you never gave the log line give
the log line that that help helps like brings it
back on on track so and there's value in all of
it like the failure in pitching brings knowledge
and every working writer has a string of failures
behind them that gets them to where they need to
be does this writer have to live in the greater
LA area it used to be yes it used to be with
without a doubt in television you had to live
in LA it since the pandemic it has broadened into
you have writers living all over the world and the
value is you can get writers who are in different
places and are at a very high level of talent by
not having them have to be in Los Angeles so I
have seen writers live in other places at this
point in the entertainment industry and succeed
but the rule of thumb for television is you should
be in Los Angeles unless if for example if you
are a known feature writer that could change
everything if you are a known feature writer
working in different places and you are making
the transition into television or streaming and
are people are aware of your films then that can
change everything to I know a gentleman who did
a thesis who his film became huge and all of the
festivals his film became huge and he never had
to start at the bottom of Television because his
films did his film did as well as it did in the
festival circuit it had clout in television and
he literally like started with selling a pilot
and started at the top and never moved to LA but
that's a rarity that's a rarity that is a rarity
you have in La the value of being in La is that
you are soaking in the business you are around
people who share your passion you around the work
and when you're around the work then you are in
an a situation where you can create opportunity
through getting your work out out there so there
there is a tremendous value in living here for
writers that live other places I often advise
don't make the move until you have three to four
very strong scripts in your portfolio then you
are making the move with a strategy that could
serve you and get you to your goal quicker do
you think stories like the one you just told
about this gentleman who wrote a feature film
that did so well or others we've heard there's
there's countless names where million dollar
right off the bat it it inspires writers or
it actually hinders them because they think I'll
be the next one and it actually could stop them
from getting a project made because they think
it's so they can just jump cut I think it does
both I agree I think that when you have these huge
success stories just like when you hear it was an
overnight success and you don't count the 10 years
that went into that overnight success and Writer's
perception of the million dollar deal happening to
what feels like a newer writer without having any
sense of all the work that went into it before
that outcome happened so I think the success
of others I writing is like yoga you have to not
compare your journey to anyone else but your own
and the idea of you have to continuously be doing
the work to be the best writer that you can be and
somebody else having success or getting further
than you should not be something that should
that you see that the dream happens every day in
the entertainment business it happens every day
so anyone that gets stuck in the victim role of of
it's not going to happen for me that is going to
mean that it chances are it won't happen to you
because you have to believe in your talent and
your gift in order order for the outcome to happen
and people who are getting these million dollar
deals are people who are doing the emotional work
in that belief as well as the work on the script
and that overall belief is getting them to that
outcome and then there's also the flip side of
sort of this aggressive like they can't surpass me
I mean some people are just hardwired differently
some people are okay with other people being ahead
of them so to speak on the on the social strata
and some people they cannot handle any type of
rivalry like that and I think that fuels certain
people too and it might actually work for them I
agree and I always fear as a former executive I
always fear the idea of the envy and the jealousy
of the more higher level writers being frightened
of lower level writers that are showing true
value and that's why I think it's so important
that all writers do the emotional work and
you can have a lower level writer and I've
seen this happen that has a tremendous voice
that threatens the upper level writers so they
won't get the positive feedback that they need
to get to that higher level or they will feel
stunted at a time when they should be celebrated
so that comes down to know your voice know your
gift believe and don't get affected by what
others say or think follow your own trajectory.